all right what's up everyone i am back
again and i am sick if you can hear it
in my voice hopefully it's not coveted
but anyways let's quickly churn out this
video before my roommate comes back and
catches me in the act as he's done many
times before
today's video will be about spanner
which
is an interesting concept i don't know
how overly relevant it'll be for systems
design interviews but i think it would
be actually a really cool thing to bring
up especially as it pertains to you know
clock synchronization and new sql in
general and how you can actually use
something like this in perhaps a large
enterprise application
okay so spanner what is it well
basically spanner is a database created
in google more or less in the last
decade so probably i think 2012 is when
the paper came out that falls under the
category of new sql so this is basically
new architectures to traditional
relational databases that try and make
improvements that make them kind of more
viable in a super scaled out environment
because as we know i've talked about sql
has many pitfalls and even though it's
the right choice a lot of the time at
super large scale it tends to fall apart
because of all of these relational
constraints and locking and things along
those lines so spanner mainly relies on
actually using synchronized clocks so
the first thing you should you know
think about when you hear that is well
clocks are never synchronized this is
distributed systems well actually they
kind of come up with an interesting
approach to trying to fix that and once
they do actually fix that they can kind
of go and make optimizations from there
in order to make a quickly performing
database
there are other companies known as i
think like yoga by db and cockroachdb
that kind of use similar ideas but i
think don't have true time to the full
extent
that spanner does and maybe have you
kind of synchronize your own clocks and
so that makes them a little bit less
reliable
okay so what are the spanner guarantees
before i go into actually how they make
them work well for starters there are
acid transactions which means that you
get atomic operations so that's achieved
to be a two-phase commit you also get
serializability and this is basically
achieved by two-phase locking so if you
recall that's kind of when you have
shared and exclusive locks on every row
um and then there are also a bunch of
replicas in order to ensure availability
that are kept consistent via paxos
instead of raft but you know same thing
for the most part there's some slight
differences between the two but that's
probably for a future video and then
linearizable reads and writes what that
means is that every single read and
write in the spanner database system is
totally ordered and trying to keep
consistent with causality
so they can do this basically all while
maintaining great performance at scale
which is pretty surprising and the way
they're able to do this is by optimizing
on that whole two-phase locking so i'm
going to go into how they actually do
that
so in order to discuss how you might
optimize on two-phase locking i should
first probably talk about the actual
issues with it um so first of all in
two-phase locking like i said a
transaction can either hold the lock on
an object
in shared or exclusive mode so reads
occur in shared mode and writes occur in
exclusive mode but recall that reads and
writes actually block one another so if
one transaction has the lock in
exclusive mode meaning it wants to write
to that row another transaction can't
read it until the first one is done
writing similarly if one transaction is
actually reading a row a second
transaction can't write to that row
until the first let's go
so what spanner does is it actually kind
of adjusts the whole system so that
making reads doesn't require grabbing a
ton of locks this is really huge for
doing things like backups or analytical
queries or anything that requires
scanning over a ton of rows that's going
to take a few minutes because if you
think about it scanning over a huge
database table in like a minute long
query means that you're going to be
having shared locks on pretty much every
single row and when that happens you
can't write to any row and so obviously
that's going to create a huge bottleneck
in any type of database system so being
able to actually eliminate the need for
locks on reading can seriously increase
performance
so how do they go about actually doing
this
well like i said they mainly want to be
doing
this on consistent snapshots
and so a consistent snapshot is
consistent with causality which means
that um basically if it writes in there
all the proceeding rights that have kind
of you know it relies on must be present
so imagine we have this timeline of a
dependency chain here and you know i
write w6 but in order to write w6 i on
my screen was seeing w1 2 3 4 and 5
those better be present in the
consistent snapshot because this is kind
of the the use case that spanner is
optimizing for
obviously if w3 was missing that would
not be consistent
additionally
so this is kind of where spanner comes
in
as opposed to using something like some
sort of version vector algorithm or some
sort of time stamp that is trying to
keep track of causality spanner actually
uses timestamps because obviously any
write that occurs physically later than
another write
you know it's going to want all the
previous writes in that snapshot which
is great and that's kind of exactly what
linearizability is
since they believe they can rely on
their server's clocks any read-only
transaction is just going to take all
the writes that were labeled with a
lower timestamp so you can see we're
performing some sort of multi-version
concurrency control here by labeling
every single write with a timestamp so
imagine i had a super long transaction
that takes two minutes and i label that
with 234
even if it finishes at 236 and the 235
right that you see at the end of the
timeline there was in the database it
won't be included in my snapshot which
is good
okay so we actually kind of have
distributed timestamps and you might be
thinking to yourself well if you know
timestamps from physical clocks aren't
reliable why aren't we just using
lampard timestamps so if you don't
remember what those are you haven't
watched my video on lanport timestamps
just know that lanport timestamps are a
way of creating a total order of all the
operations that happen on a database by
basically propagating them between
clients and databases and that way you
can kind of keep track of which
operations are concurrent and which
operations are causally dependent on one
another that all being said lanport
timestamps do have some pretty big
issues here i mean the first thing and
kind of the biggest is that they're not
linearizable
you can have a bunch of writes that are
concurrent according to lanport
timestamps but still didn't happen at
the same time
so this is kind of problematic when
you're doing full table queries because
i might have according to some arbitrary
ordering of nodes in you know like the
lan port ordering i might have two
writes where the database thinks they're
concurrent and so as a result you know
let's say we have w1 and w2 and the
database says okay w1 occurred before w2
but the reality of the situation is just
because of that random node ordering and
the fact that lanport timestamps think
they're concurrent
uh it says w1 came first but the truth
is w2 could have been written an hour
earlier and we might have wanted that in
our snapshot so they're not linearizable
in the sense that they're not consistent
with physical time
additionally
if there is any communication between
you know end users on their own outside
of the actual you know write and read
path of the database itself lanport
timestamps can't reflect that for
example you know if i see a cooking
video or more likely i don't know some
batty on tick tock on my friend's phone
that i then say oh i'm going to go
follow her
what tick tock now can't do is kind of
see the the causality or the the
decision making that led me to make that
follow action it can't see that i first
saw this um interaction on my friend's
device because my personal user
generated lan port timestamp doesn't
reflect you know what i've been doing
outside of reads and writes directly to
the database
um time can actually fix both of these
issues
another thing is why not just use a
centralized timestamp every single write
could just hit a server first um well
obviously any time you say the word
centralized two things should be coming
up in your head the first is that that's
a single point of failure um assuming
we're not using any sort of redundancy
or like consensus algorithm to determine
the time stamp that's obviously going to
be very problematic and then the second
is that this is just going to be a huge
bottleneck imagine if i'm in australia
and um you know i want to make a right
to a true time or a spanner instance in
australia but the the whole ordering
server is in america that's going to
hugely slow down my right
okay so what is true tag because i keep
kind of floating this phrase around but
now i'll actually discuss it so true
time is google's implementation of a
time stamp where you basically are
returning an uncertainty interval so
instead of saying like okay i think this
event happened at x time what google
instead does is perform a series of
calculations based on a bunch of
possible ranges of error and return a
minimum and a maximum interval for that
time step where they're basically just
saying like okay we're pretty damn close
to sure that whenever this event did
happen it happened within this bound
um
okay
so
in terms of um
you know how clocks actually work in
most distributed systems recall that
they're really not too insane
but
in terms of spanner rights this is kind
of how we go ahead and make sure that
true time is actually working as it
should be
so every single right to spanner has to
wait a time period equal to the length
of the uncertainty bound so basically if
i have t min and t max i subtract t min
from t max that's the length of the
uncertainty interval and every single
time a write reaches the database i have
to actually go ahead and weight that
length before it gets committed
why do we do that well i'll explain it
now so imagine we have right one that
occurs at eight comma ten it means that
we don't know exactly when um the write
gets there but we know it's between time
stamp eight and time stamp ten so what
spanner will actually do is it's gonna
say okay
the right is going to go ahead and wait
two seconds before committing the reason
for this is it means that no matter when
the right actually originally reached
the server we know is between time 8 and
time 10. so if we wait two seconds it
means that the right is going to be
committed after time 10 which means that
any subsequent reads must also have um
you know like after time 10 in its
interval so say r1 comes along and reads
w1 we know that r1 is going to be after
time 10 right because we know that w1
occurred after time 10 and so even if
you know the time minimum of r1 is
before 10 we know that the maximum has
to be greater than 10 because we know
that
you know the the read is going to be at
some period where the bound must include
times greater than 10. so now if we just
use the later timestamp for both the
write and the read we see that r1 comes
after w1 so that's a pretty clever trick
that they use however it comes with the
following problem
every single time we're waiting the
uncertainty interval on rights that's
greatly increasing the latency on rights
so kind of the challenge of spanner is
to make sure that every single time
you're making a right we're minimizing
the uncertainty interval as low as
possible
how do we do this well google actually
uses specialized hardware here they put
atomic clocks in every single data
center and synchronize them very
frequently that's like every 30 seconds
so compared to traditional clocks which
are synchronizing using network time
protocol over the internet and possibly
even synchronizing with some potentially
unreliable servers
google is using this kind of specialized
design of the hardware in order to make
sure that those clocks are as
synchronized as humanly possible
in this way they're able to kind of
achieve this super high throughput and
non-locking of reads
okay so in conclusion although it's
probably not that practical that you
might talk about one of these in an
actual systems design interview
if the the concept of you know
distributed clocks comes up it's very
interesting to mention how you can use
specialized hardware to kind of get a
lower uncertainty bound on reads and
writes and as a result of that you can
do some really interesting things even
creating you know like a super scalable
sql system
i think this is a pretty interesting
topic and it seems like most of the
distributed systems courses tend to
mention it because it's actually i don't
know pretty revolutionary in the sense
that people haven't really just you know
tried to optimize on time like this
before
but uh yeah i hope you guys enjoyed this
video i'm gonna keep thinking of topics
to talk about and then probably within
the next i don't know 10 or 15 videos
we'll start actually doing some practice
problems